[Music]
foreign
I want that fighter strip for parts by
tomorrow
let's go get paid
that worked
we cannot trust those officers they take
our credits now but let's stop them from
stabbing Us in the back
next
hit that button
[Music]
nice one
hang on tight little buddy
I was just leaving yeah
okay okay we'll figure this out
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Nick
this is getting bad
[Music]
dick Ferrick
thank you
I think that went pretty well right
[Music]
that was close
95 I got the package where are you
waiting for you and jaunt us hope
were you seen I said I got it what else
matters
anytime soon
um well they'll probably forgive me
[Music]
there's Johnson's hope we made it next
Pokemon
[Music]
hey Andy
you're late kid Doc is waiting what are
you worried no
okay
no picture Troy what
be careful
donkey's a broker not a friend she can't
be trusted who can out here
see you back at the ship
round two and I still like my odds
okay vess back already
I told you she's fresh but she's good
who's this
just a friend
join us
job was more complicated than you said
Danka
you lived
hey these aren't toys
they're Investments
wait
we haven't met
don't really know many of you
stealing illegal Contraband running with
syndicates I could say you're a threat
to the Empire
but I won't have to if you're smart
[Music]
thanks but I'm smart enough to get
myself out of trouble you pay the tax
just like everyone else whoa kid let's
just relax
[Music]
you won't make a doctor shower alive
Maybe
old Troopers we have reports of a
fugitive in Georgia's hope moved
apprehend
Italian
uh could be I told you not to trust her
not the first time we brought around the
empire
thank you
need to leave yeah no kidding
[Music]
[Applause]
are we good nothing on the sensors yet
anybody on the sensors now
I've got one
I feel inclined to remind you that we
should shake the Empire quickly thanks
I'm working on it
[Music]
Andy get us out of here
let's jump
we made it
[Music]
hey
got your new toy
[Music]
so where do we go next
anywhere we want
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Star Wars Outlaws coming 2024.
thank you
[Music]
there you are
away from
thank you
time to vanish
get back here
stand and fight you worm
away
two
[Music]
alhamdulillah
I am glad you are safe
[Music]
alhamdulillah a first of many
achievements to combust him we should
only hope
there's still much work to do
[Music]
while our Focus was on our rule full of
quietly scouted the city for where we
could erect more bureaus
I have found dwellings in three
districts that are most unassuming
Abid and Rebecca have arrived from
alamut and set off to al-abasiya and
karch
I will make my way to sharkia shortly
and I will join Rebecca in Cara
who had corruption is as common as the
irid heir
see Abuja fire about some things he's
been working on then come find us
have a look awesome I may have something
that is of interest to you
[Music]
resourceful as always my thanks abujafar
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the place
what do you see in kidu
[Music]
let us reconsider the approach
thank you
[Music]
act as usual a girl who likes me said
she and Ali's followers are trying to
overthrow the prince what Madness they
will surely fail
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hey
the sky is safe my friend
survey the area
there is my target
you learn your play
oh
[Music]
this is what I wish to know and no more
than he died this day
[Music]
thank you
the rda's breed poisoned our world
secure the perimeters
everything from us
me
I was trained in their ways their
technology
their weapons
things that are not they should not know
and then one day they left Hell's Gate
is under attack evacuate Now kill all
the navi children but before they did
our teacher saved us and put us to sleep
this is your only chance to survive
and there I remain for 15 years
until one day
I awoke
and I was free
[Applause]
to explore my world
free to decide who I was going to be
ever what I was meant to do
[Music]
now you see what they kept you from
now Pandora is under attack again
don't let the Navi get in our way get
rid of them and I have a choice to make
I choose to protect my home
foreign
s
I am no longer
I am not me
[Music]
sivako
when entering Mount calf your mission is
clear find Prince Hassan and bring him
back to persepolis
however Mount calf becomes a prison full
of hostile
foreign
[Music]
now separated from your allies you
discover a grand Citadel full of
mysteries where time flows differently
what is this sorcery the past coexists
with the future
this cursed Lynn exploration is
everything
this is a semi-open world that delivers
new Secrets as we find new powers
to reach new
ills and your sense of timing
a trademark of Prince of Persia
what I like to stop during this Epic
Journey you won't be the only one
trapped in Mount calf goddess and
blacksmith to the Gods
some dwellers are willing to help you
While others are more reluctant
[Music]
however Sargon is not a warrior like any
other
[Music]
he is a wild beast known for being
elusive ruthless and extremely skillful
on the battlefield
[Music]
fueled by anger he constantly puts his
life on the line to perform devastating
attacks
all right
time powers are back
but this time
what the hell was that not only in your
hands
to face such a challenge Master a new
side to these time powers and defy
gravity
by combining all these skills together
you can express your creativity to solve
Mount caps Mysteries
foreign
and execute brutal combos in epic combat
[Music]
and that's just a glimpse of what Prince
of Persia the Lost Crown is all about
on behalf of the team from Ubisoft
mobile we cannot wait for you to put
your hands on the game
it releases on January 18 2024 on all
platforms
get ready
[Music]